for the last eight months I've been
training to run six marathons you five
days across as a hard desert the math of
the Saba is the toughest for race in the
world I will enjoy 130 degree heat
massive sand dunes and complete
exhaustion hi I am James Marshall with
the help of my friends I've been
training for the 2013 math and to saw
now that's all done so let's get on with
it
the math into Scilab is a self survival
race I need to carry all of my own food
and supplies for the for 140 miles
I must measure down to the last calorie
exactly what I need to survive Morocco
that's wrong going now really yeah I've
got a Morocco yeah fantastic it's got to
be good luck yes absolutely the drivers
from Morocco Morocco here I come
two people whack seven or eight rockin
army vehicles come pick us up because
the bosses can't get out to where the
bivouac is which is somewhere out there
where here we are the 8th refers to her
this is a ridiculous race a marathon is
26.2 miles the math in the Saab is 140
to 150 miles in the middle of the Sahara
Desert there are 1,100 athletes from
more than 50 countries so I'm told the
race route is altered each year to
account for regional wars and political
instability yeah like that fills me the
confidence
we've been going for going changeable to
off hours
yeah I'm Irie Irie not sure of course
happy to tell you underprepared okay
just completed stage one it was actually
a lot tougher than I thought it was
gonna be hello but of course and you see
my feet are blistered they're not
particularly healthy but it was great
it's a really good day today one done
and I didn't puke although I might in a
minute now that you see me running the
first marathon tuning to episode 2 to
watch things go south